zu dieser pressekonferenz zur corona
lage und seiner neuen app passt dass du
wirst dich den bundesminister für
gesundheit
entspann gehäuse und fritz den
projektmanager von ibm am kopf dass der
projekte für koch bass von der firma dbm
und herrn prof sonntag klar wieder wie
präsident ist robert koch institut das
seien sie uns herzlich willkommen heißen
nämlich bevor der minister beginnt kurz
zwei sachen sagen erstens hier ist eine
veranstaltung der bundespressekonferenz
wir sind ein verein der journalistinnen
und journalisten organisiert wir sind
nicht teil der bundesregierung das ist
uns wichtig zu sagen wir gewährleisten
dass unsere mitglieder hier fragen
stellen können an die regierung und
freuen uns dass diese gesten dass unsere
gäste auch in diesen schweren tagen des
letzten jahres auch uns zu gast sind
wird zeit erlauben wäre auch live
übertragen deswegen sage ich das noch
mal herzlich bedanken muss man kann der
sender phoenix für die gebärden
dolmetscher
wir haben eine begrenzte zeit wie immer
in diesen zeiten
deswegen bitte ich um eine frage und
eine nachfrage und wenn sie dann noch
eine frage haben setzen wir wieder
hinten auch die liste er lieber fällt
auf meine damen und herren sie sehen
einen zufriedenen bundesminister für
gesundheit der trend den wir in den
letzten wochen auch schon hier haben
beschreiben können den wir gesehen haben
er ist ein guter und er setzt sich fort
das mache ich an 3s fest die
infektionszahlen gehen runter deutlich
runter die intensivstationen leeren sich
von coop 19 patienten die behandelt
werden müssen und die impfzahlen steigen
weiter auch mit guter geschwindigkeit
wir hatten gestern den zweithöchsten
wert bei den täglichen impfungen seit
beginn der impfkampagne
damit sind mehr lockerungen möglich wir
können wieder mehr freiheit mehr
normalität wagen und wählte vor drei
vier wochen gedacht dass wir ins tänzen
unter 20 so deutlich und umfassend in
einigen bundesländern schon einstellig
sehen würden das ist eine sehr sehr gute
eine sehr ermutigende entwicklung
gleichwohl geht es weiterhin darum
dieses erreichte
auch abzusichern und die zahlen noch
weiter runter zu bringen ich weiß nach
dem motto immer noch ein weiter aber
umso tiefer wir kommen gerade auch mit
beginn der sommerzeit desto länger
werden wir auch etwas von diesem erfolg
haben und desto weniger geben wir
mutationen die chance sich zu verbreiten
und wir sehen gerade im vereinigten
königreich die eine noch das eine noch
höhere impfquote hat als wir wie schnell
eine mutation dann trotzdem wieder auch
zu hohen instanzen führen kann und umso
geringer wir insgesamt die inzidenz
bringen und halten desto schwerer machen
wir es auch jede mutation dabei hilft
testen und dabei hilft impfen und zu
beiden wenn ich kurz was sagen
in deutschland haben wir inzwischen eine
einzigartige test infrastruktur
aufgebaut
in jeder ecke vom münsterland bis in die
hauptstadt vom bodensee bis zum ostsee
leicht zugänglich und kostenlos für
jeden ein bürger test dieses angebot
wird jeden tag hunderttausendfach
millionenfach genutzt um für sich selbst
sicherheit zu bekommen aber auch um an
möglichkeiten des alltags wieder
teilnehmen zu können ob es der
einzelhandel ist die gastronomie oder
der sport um diese tests struktur
schnell aufzubauen haben die
wirtschaftliche anreize gesetzt und die
bürokratischen hürden sehr niedrig
gehalten
das haben einige anbieter offenbar
schamlos ausgenutzt
sie haben tests abgerechnet in teilen
ist immer wichtig viele machen ihre
arbeit ordentlich engagiert bei guter
qualität der da aber einige haben tests
abgerechnet die sie nie gemacht haben
und möglicherweise sogar test kosten
angesetzt die es nicht gegeben hat um
das klar zu sagen das ist betrug
das muss mit aller härte des gesetzes
geahndet werden und deswegen finde ich
es richtig und unterstütze ausdrücklich
dass die länder das die
staatsanwaltschaften auch mit der
entsprechenden härte vorgehen bis hin
dass es ja haftbefehl gegeben hat das
signal muss sein betrug lohnt sich nicht
wer betrügt wird hart bestraft auch in
diesem bereich
und wir haben auf die betrugsfälle
reagiert indem wir eine neue test
verordnung vorgelegt haben gestern in
die abstimmung gegeben haben mit den
ländern und den bundesressorts was
übrigens zeigt wenn ich das mal
inzwischen satz sagen darf es gibt keine
verordnung des bundesministers für
gesundheit die nicht ressort
abgestimmtes mit allen anderen
bundesressort keine das ist so bei
verordnung bei jeder verordnung der
bundesregierung eines ministers gibt es
eine abstimmung aller ministerien
insofern ist das natürlich immer eine
miteinander abgestimmte regelung diese
test verordnung sieht vor dass wir mehr
kontrollen möglich machen honorare der
preisentwicklung anpassen
wir wollen natürlich das testzentrum
wirtschaftlich betrieben werden können
kriminelle bereicherung wollen wir aber
unterbinden
ein zweites standbein auf dem weg in die
normalität ist das impfen
47 prozent der deutschen sind mindestens
einmal geimpft wenn wir nehmen's
bereitschaft von 75 prozent annehmen die
sich auch in den umfragen widerspiegelt
dann sind drei von vier impfwilligen im
breiten erwachsenen stand heute
mindestens einmal geimpft und das ist
denke ich auch wenn wir die entwicklung
der letzten woche nehmen die dynamik die
das gewonnen hat bei allen jetzt zum
teil auch noch warten auf einen
impftermin aber doch eine gute
entwicklung fast jeder vierte ist
vollständig geimpft hat einen vollen
impfschutz und nun wollen wir heute auch
im rahmen dieser kroner lage ein neues
werkzeug vorstellen dass das impfen noch
attraktiver macht damit impfen schützt
man sich und schützt man andere aber
impfen erlaubt eben auch wieder mehr
freiheiten gibt mehr möglichkeiten und
um den impfstatus nachzuweisen gibt es
zum einen den bekannten gelben impfpass
den internationalen pass auf der welle
und der wird übrigens auch weiterhin
seine gültigkeit behalten das ist
wichtig auch für diejenigen die
möglicherweise aus welchen gründen auch
immer ist nicht digital wollen
aber wichtig ist eben zusätzlich haben
wir uns auf europäischer ebene und das
war ja der erste wichtige schritt auf
gemeinsame standards für einen digitalen
impfnachweis geeinigt auf dieser
grundlage haben wir
mit ibm uhr beste und gastitel den kopf
pass entwickelt und konnten bereits ende
mai also eine woche nach endgültiger
festlegung der spezifikation durch die
eu mit dem feld starten wir mussten
erstmal die eu spezifikation abwarten
dann haben wir den feldtest gestartet
und nun nachdem dieser tests erfolgreich
waren beginnen wir in dieser woche mit
dem rollout des systems der
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte sowie das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik haben zugestimmt und
so kann es losgehen wichtig ist schritt
für schritt werden sich jetzt
impfzentren arztpraxen sowie apotheken
an das system anschließen um europäisch
interoperable impf bescheinigung
ausstellen zu können
das bedeutet aber auch um auch hier
klares erwartungsmanagement zu machen es
geht jetzt los schritt für schritt
werden impfzentren arztpraxen apotheken
angeschlossen aber nicht alle sind heute
oder morgen schon angeschlossen
also es wird jetzt nach und nach immer
mehr geben die mitmachen die ersten sind
auch schon dabei aber es werden eben
nicht gleich sofort alle sein können
innerhalb der nächsten wochen sind dann
alle dabei so das so ist die zielmarke
bis ende juni der kof pass in
deutschland für alle die wollen auch zur
verfügung steht und entsprechend auf dem
handy man sich das eintragen lassen kann
und vor allem die app jetzt auch in den
app-stores entsprechend zur verfügung
steht nach und nach in den nächsten
tagen und stunden um sie sich
entsprechend runterzuladen
auch die nachträgliche ausstellung des
qr-codes beginnen schrittweise das geht
ja um diejenigen die schon vollständig
geimpft sind
die sich natürlich fragen wie komme ich
jetzt an mein digitales zertifikat viele
bundesländer werden in diesen tagen
beginnen postalisch den qr-code zu
versenden
bei den impfzentren da wo ihm
vollständig personen bereits geimpft
wurden und auch die apotheken werden
daneben schrittweise zusätzlich zu den
impfenden stellen
sich anschließend die ersten haben schon
begonnen und können dann entsprechend
das digitale im zertifikat erstellen
in den nächsten wochen werden dann
übrigens auch test und genesenen
informationen in der app zu speichern
seien sie genau das alles funktioniert
wird der fritz gleich nochmal erklären
ich persönlich nutze das ganze oder
werde das ganze nutzen in der korona
vanek wir integrieren es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten das eine ist die korona
waren ebwo neben den testen dann auch
das impfen integriert sein wird oder es
geht eben darum sozusagen das papier in
das gerät zu bringen mit dem kot den wir
auch extra im kopf passt der fgw extra
entwickelt mit dem kopf bass und für
diejenigen die kontrollieren müssen in
den restaurants zum beispiel oder im
einzelhandel gibt es eine app die es
dann möglich macht die entsprechenden
zertifikate zu lesen und zu verifizieren
sie sehen wir hatten angekündigt dass es
dieses werkzeug bis zum ende des zweiten
quartals geben können soll
wir halten hier wort vor den
sommerferien gibt es eine europäische
lösung impfungen digital nachzuweisen
einfach auf dem handy europaweit gültig
der kopf passiert dann in rostock
castrop rauxel und tirschenreuth
gleichermaßen verfügbar sein und
akzeptiert werden und das ziel ist
voraussetzung ist natürlich dass die
europäischen mitgliedstaaten jetzt
ähnlich schnell mit 10
ziel ist aber dass dann auch in helsinki
amsterdam oder auf mallorca
genau dieses digitale in zertifikat auch
gelesen werden kann und damit setzen wir
als europäische union einen standard den
es länderübergreifend auf der welt
bisher nicht gibt wenn uns das jetzt
gelingt und das ist glaube ich im
größten land in der europäischen union
heute ein wichtiger schritt
dann setzen wir als europäische union
auf standards für den internationalen
reiseverkehr und ums impfen dankeschön
jenen danke minister hermina ja genau
meine damen und herren die zahlen
entwickeln sich im moment weiter sehr
gut die bundes heute sieben tage sind
sie denn sinkt kontinuierlich sie liegt
heute bei 19 fällen pro 100.000
und von den 412 landkreisen in unserem
land liegt im moment kein einziger mehr
über 100 und nur zwölf landkreise haben
eine inzidenz die über 50 liegt es gibt
96 landkreise die liegen sogar mit einer
inzidenz unter 10
glücklicherweise geht es auch mit den
impfungen sehr gut voran
heute sind rund 47 prozent der menschen
in deutschland mindestens einmal geimpft
und rund 24 prozent sind vollständig
geimpft werden auch deutlich weniger
patienten wegen cupid 19 und unseren
krankenhäusern behandelt auch auf den
intensivstationen und glücklicherweise
gehen auch die todesfälle in verbindung
mit 19 kontinuierlich zurück all das
sind erfreuliche entwicklungen und
trotzdem ist die pandemie leider noch
nicht vorbei die situation die wir jetzt
erreicht haben haben wir erreicht weil
wir die maßnahmen haben und weil wir
impfungen haben
das muss uns auch immer bewusst sein was
man auch sehen muss ist dass die
fallzahlen natürlich immer noch
vergleichsweise hoch sind viel höher als
im vergangenen jahr um diese zeit
tatsächlich exakt heute zehnmal so hoch
wie am 10 juni letzten jahres
sie können auch regional und nach
altersgruppen natürlich noch immer stark
variieren und die intensivstation sind
natürlich immer noch sehr belastet und
es sterben auch immer noch viele
menschen in verbindung mit 19
aktuell sind es immer noch mehrere
hundert menschen pro woche
wir haben uns in der pandemie an diese
hohen krankheits und todeszahlen gewöhnt
es ist generell schwierig sich solche
zahlen vorzustellen aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen hinter jeder dieser zahl
stehen menschen menschen mit ihren
familien freunden und nachbarn
wir haben gemeinsam viel erreicht in den
letzten monaten aber wie gesagt die
pandemie ist leider noch nicht vorbei
und das wird besonders sichtbar wenn wir
uns die situation in alten und
pflegeheimen anschauen in der zweiten
welle
da waren alten und pflegeheime massiv
betroffen in den letzten januarwoche 20
21 wurden mehr als 450 ausbrüche
registriert danach gingen die ausbrüche
sehr stark zurück das lag zum einen
daran dass durch die maßnahmen die
inzidenz in der
generell zurückging und das lag
natürlich auch daran dass immer mehr
menschen in altenpflegeheimen geimpft
wurden
obwohl es dann zur dritten welle
gekommen ist obwohl die inzidenz in der
gesamtbevölkerung wieder stark
angestiegen sind blieb die zahl der
ausbrüche in den altersheimen niedrig
sind deutlich weniger bewohner erkrankt
oder gestorben
das spricht für eine hohe wirksamkeit
der impfung aber die ausbrüche in alten
pflegeheimen sind trotzdem noch nicht
vollständig verschwunden wenn wir hier
sprechen sind aktuell 40 ausbrüche immer
noch aktiv auch mit hospitalisierungen
und todesfällen
dafür gibt es drei gründe sind nicht
immer alle bewohner geimpft zb
ungeimpfte neuzugänge auch das personal
ist nicht immer geben hier sind die
anteile sehr unterschiedlich in den
einzelnen räumen
und dazu kommt dass die impfstoffe zwar
sehr wirksam beim verhindern von
symptomatischen erkrankungen und
todesfällen sind aber geimpfte können
sie eben trotzdem noch infizieren
das virus ergreift also jede noch so
kleine chance
wie sollten wir ihn nicht geben das
zeigt wie wichtig es zusätzlich zu den
impfungen ist weiter schutzmaßnahmen
einzuhalten und das zeigt auch dass
selbst bei einem hohen impfquoten in
diesen sehr wohl im bereich nur
vorsichtig gelockert werden darf die
gefahr ist eben noch nicht vorüber das
saas kopf 2 virus das wird auch nicht
mehr verschwinden
entscheidend ist dass wir das virus
unter kontrolle halten und auch unter
kontrolle bringen langfristig deshalb
müssen wir die fallzahlen weiter senken
sind immer noch zu hoch und wir müssen
vor allem die fallzahlen auch niedrig
halten kontinuierlich
das ist mit impfung allein im moment
noch nicht zu erreichen denn viele
menschen sind ja noch nicht geimpft und
sind entsprechend noch nicht geschützt
deshalb bleiben die basismaßnahmen
vorerst weiter so wichtig die asl regeln
die reduktion von kontakten das testen
die nutzen der korona warne die
isolierung quarantäne
um infektionsketten zu verhindern und
einige mehr sie kennen alle die
werkzeuge und jedes dieser werkzeug hat
einen wert und deshalb bleibt es weiter
so wichtig auch kontrolliert und
umsichtig zu öffnen und die zeitlichen
abschnitten
das gilt uns auch dann wenn jetzt in
immer mehr landkreisen eine sehr
niedrige sieben tage incidents vorkommt
unter zehn ja sogar 0 hatten wir ja aber
auch dann müssen wir uns unser umfeld
weiterhin schützen und umsichtig
verhalten und unsere kontakte gering
halten denn diese sieben tage incidents
ist natürlich immer nur eine
momentaufnahme
sie kann sich rasch wieder ändern das
virus kann jederzeit wieder mitgebracht
werden oder es kann vor ort infektionen
geben die nicht erkannt wurden und die
zur weiteren ansteckung führen eine
niedrige 7 tages inzidenz ist ein
großartiger erfolg
sie bedeutet aber eben leider nicht dass
alles überstanden ist und das virus
nicht mehr zurückkommt wir alle wünschen
uns öffnungen und normalität
aber das geht nur wenn wir das virus
weiter gemeinsam unter kontrolle bringen
und auch unter kontrolle halten
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir haben
die ausstellung des zertifikats in den
vergangenen tagen in impfzentren und in
einigen arztpraxen in deutschland
erfolgreich verprobt wir werden heute
nicht nur den produktiven feldtest
beenden sondern wir werden beginnen den
produktiven wirkbetrieb schritt für
schritt in deutschland zu aktivieren
auf der anderen seite werden wir aber
auch den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
möglichkeit offerieren dass sie ihre
digitalen impf zertifikate in einer
mobilen anwendung nämlich dem kopf das
digital verwalten können
hierzu ist zu sagen dass die kaufpreise
anwendung einfach durch jung und alt zu
bedienen ist und im wesentlichen sich
durch drei relevante merkmale auszeit
schnitt zum einen natürlich das
abfotografieren des qr codes vom imf
zertifikat und der anschließenden
speicherung ausschließlich auf dem
mobilen gerät des bürgers unter bürgerin
zum zweiten ein integrität scheck wir
akzeptieren nur im zertifikate die eu
konform sind und die von autorisierten
stellen in deutschland ausgestellt sind
von den ärzten von den impfzentren und
in zukunft auch von den apotheken und
drittens werden wir signalisieren ob ein
vollständiger impfstatus vorliegt und
der beachtung der fachlichen regeln
so ist zum beispiel dem vollständigen
impfschutz zurzeit nur dann gegeben wenn
14 tage nach der zweiten impfung
vergangen sind
die mobile anwendung kopf pass ist
mittlerweile in den app stores verfügbar
in allen drei üblichen app stores
verfügbar
sie kann heruntergeladen werden und
natürlich auch und das hoffe ich sehr
stark auch mit positivem feedback für
das projektteam versehen werden
gestatten sie mir an dieser stelle herr
minister sparen hat es angedeutet wir
hatten zehn tage zeit vorliegen der eu
spezifikation und in diesen zehn tagen
hat nicht nur das projektteam der em
sondern auch unsere partner insbesondere
hubert die kollegen von buffed digital
von bechtle aber auch die mitarbeiter
des bundesministeriums und des lka sehr
intensiv gearbeitet wie auch die im
zentrums mitarbeiter und die kollegen in
den kassenärztlichen vereinigungen und
in den arztpraxen
wir haben es geschafft in dieser kurzen
zeit das system an die rampe zu fahren
und nun für die bürgerinnen und bürger
nutzbar zu haben
wir werden das wurde angedeutet nun
schritt für schritt die impfzentren
befähigen des fc kalt auszustellen das
ist bereits gestartet wir haben jetzt
schon in der fläche vierstellige
produktive im zertifikate in deutschland
verfügbar
und wir werden natürlich ebenso
schritt für schritt jetzt die einzelnen
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen und damit
die arztpraxen in den bundesländern
aktivieren
gleichermaßen werden die bundesländer
befähigt dass die bereits geimpften
zertifikate jetzt ausgestellt werden
können und vor der sommerpause
postalisch den bürgerinnen und bürgern
zur verfügung gestellt werden
die sommerpause ist noch mal ein gutes
stichwort
wir wollen natürlich dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger das zertifikat
für ihre reise nutzen können wir haben
dazu uns sehr bemüht in der ersten
gruppe der mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union dabei zu sein und bei
den ersten eu interoperabilitätstests
das zertifikat zu verpesten
das ist wichtig dass die zertifikate die
hier in deutschland erzeugt werden auch
in den ländern der europäischen union
gelesen werden können und auf der
anderen seite konnten wir nachweisen
dass die zertifikate die in anderen
mitgliedstaaten erzeugt werden
auch hier in deutschland geprüft werden
können
wie soll die prüfung erfolgen auch dafür
gibt es eine zweite mobile applikation
das ist der kopf pass der die
zertifikate der bürgerinnen und bürger
einlesen kann zum beispiel am flughafen
oder in anderen lokationen und wo dem
bürger signalisiert wird dass er einen
vollständigen impfschutz zur verfügung
hat und insofern seine reise fortsetzen
kann
beide mobile anwendungen sind verfügbar
der kopf pass und der kauf passt check
und wir freuen uns auf eine intensive
nutzung durch die bürgerinnen und bürger
vielen dank vielen dank herr fritz wir
kommen nicht gemerkt ich habe ich gesagt
you be virtual speaker offensichtlich
sitzt in köln
aber wir kommen zu ihren fragen und
beginnen drüben auf der rechten seite da
sind jetzt ja
schönen dank die frage geht an minister
sparen beim digitalen impfpass sollen
beispielsweise die apotheken generierten
qr-code glaube 18 euro abrechnen dürfen
die frage ist wie kommt wenn sie
erklären wie dieser preis zustande kommt
also zuerst einmal geht es ja hier vor
allem die nachträgliche erstellung
dieses zertifikats bei denjenigen die
schon vollständig geimpft sind aber eben
jetzt die noch nicht kriegen konnten
ansonsten ist ja eher regelhafte prozess
klar manch einer mag sich später
entscheiden
aber viele werden ja mit ihrer
vollständigen impfung sich im
impfzentrum in der arztpraxis ist auch
ausstellen lassen
und jetzt geht es um die frage wie wir
das möglichst schnell auch nachholen
können für die fast jeder hat gesagt
jeder vierte ist schon voll geschützt
für die vielen millionen die schon im
vollständigen impfschutz haben und das
digital haben wollen
viele werden angeschrieben werden können
da jetzt relativ kostengünstig laufen
durch die länder und dann ein qr code
bekommen den sie einst kennen können
übrigens man kann ja nicht den von
seinem bruder benutzen war natürlich der
name und das geburtsdatum mit dabei ist
und damit auch der personalausweis
natürlich immer mit gecheckt werden
können soll an der an der stelle ist er
in arztpraxen nach tragen können da geht
es dann nach aufwand
es wird jetzt nach und nach das haben
wir auch beauftragt in den praxis
software systemen der arztpraxen
sozusagen integriert da ist der aufwand
deutlich geringer da gibt es dann
niedrige einstellige euro vergütung oder
es muss wirklich händisch gemacht werden
da gibt es eine höhere vergütung da sind
wir bei der vergütung der apotheken 18
euro für eine prüfung die ja auch
vorzunehmen ist es geht ja sowohl in der
arztpraxis wie wir in der apotheke um
eine dokumentenprüfung das ist ja nicht
einfach nur mal gescannt sondern ist
neun und apotheker sind darin geübt
dokumente zu prüfen
auch bei den rezepten beispielsweise
gibt es durchaus den versuch von
fälschungen bei rezepten und es soll
eben eine tatsächliche prüfung
stattfinden mit entsprechendem
kontrollaufwand und der
spiegelt sich eben in dieser vergütung
dann wieder wichtig ist es geht hier vor
allem um diejenigen die nachträglich das
eintragen lassen und es geht eben um
diejenigen die jetzt auch nicht
schriftlich werden erreicht werden
können weil nicht alle impfzentren wir
haben leider kein nationales register
hätte gerne eines gehabt aber die
debatte war wie sie war kontrovers und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt eben auf
diesem weg machen nachfrage nur ganz
kurz als auch vor dem hintergrund der
jüngsten kosten kritik durch den
bundesrechnungshof ist das ein preis wo
sie sagen er ist nicht zu beanstanden
es ist es ist wie immer beides wissen
sie hätten wir den preis genommen der am
ende den aufwand nicht angemessen
berücksichtigt würden nicht viele
apotheken mitmachen dann würden würden
manche möglicherweise öffentlich sagen
na super
die sagen ich kann in die apotheke gehen
aber ich kann gar nicht weil meine
apotheke macht nicht mit
oder sie müssen eine vergütung machen
die den aufwand widerspiegelt damit
möglichst viele der 19.000 apotheken mit
machen sie denn ich gezwungen als
apotheke mitzumachen und wir haben finde
ich ein hohes interesse dass jetzt viele
bürgerinnen und bürger zügig tatsächlich
auch zügig tatsächlich auch ihre nach
eintragung sozusagen machen können
deswegen geht es immer um eine vergütung
die den aufwand auch widerspiegelt aber
es wird von beiden seiten das ist immer
so wenn sie vergütung festlegen
möglicherweise kritik geben haben jetzt
auch andere themen gerade die frage von
vergütungen bezahlung entsprechend in
der kritik steht
ich kann nur sagen bis jetzt ist es uns
gelungen die dinge immer relativ zügig
die wir aufbauen wollten in der pandemie
in der notsituation dann auch aufzubauen
intensivbetten sind schnell entstanden
es gebe beschlüsse der länder die zahl
verdoppeln zu wollen der intensivbetten
und des corona kabinetts und diesen
ansatz haben wir damals rechnung
getragen
es gab den wunsch dass schnell test
infrastrukturen entstehen am liebsten
gestern als heute weil man öffnen wollte
und es gibt den wunsch dass schnell
digitale im zertifikate flächendeckend
ausgestellt werden können ohne dass es
in arztpraxen und impfzentren zu langen
warteschlangen und ansammlungen
und wenn es schnell gehen soll und
angemessen ein aufwand widergespiegelt
werden soll
dann geht es eben auch um eine
angemessene vergütung
herr kollege ich wollte auch auf den
ersten großen bericht des
bundesrechnungshofs wonach politik
kommen der ihnen jahr massiv
geldverschwendung vorwurf also es geht
um die masken für apotheke dann um die
freiheiten pauschalen für die kliniken
aber ich wollte auf einen punkt zu
sprechen kommen nämlich die zusätzliche
schaffung der intensivbetten wo er jedes
klinikum 50.000 euro für ein neues bett
bekommen sollte 700 millionen wurden
abgerufen das heißt knapp 14.000 neue
intensiv bettenburgen bezahlt der
bundesrechnungshof sagt er kann dieser
intensivbetten nicht finden
sie konnten auch keine statistik
irgendwie zeigen ist es für sie ein
anlass wenn man jetzt sieht dass es
insgesamt heute nur eine kapazität von
24.000 intensivbetten gibt aber geld für
14.000 neue bezahlt wurde
das mal zu überprüfen ob da
möglicherweise auch wieder
bundesrechnungshof vermutet
mitnahmeeffekte geschehens sind und da
betten aufgebaut warum sind die so
offensichtlich gar nicht existieren
es ist nicht nur anlass ist wird er
natürlich in diskussion mit den ländern
von uns schon seit monaten adressiert
wir haben weil glaube auch zu gestern
ich war gestern auch im
haushaltsausschuss jetzt zu
verschiedenen themen da auch noch mal
einen bericht über sand jetzt auf bundes
länder bezogen was die zahl der nach den
finanz volumina jedenfalls geschaffenen
intensivbetten angeht und die länder
müssen natürlich auch ein nachweis
erbringen über die geschaffenen betten
idealerweise und auch das ist unser
ansinnen krankenhaus scharf also auf das
einzelne krankenhaus bezogen aber wissen
sie es jetzt auch eine sehr
grundsätzliche frage des föderalen
miteinanders ich kann mich an die
gesetzgebung noch sehr gut erinnern
das ist ja alles muss immer mal sich
noch mal ändern muss alles über ein jahr
her
die gesetzgebung zu der intensivbetten
förderung ich glaube den beschluss von
bund und ländern die intensiv
kapazitäten in deutschland verdoppeln zu
wollen
ich weiß noch wie auch unter anderem
richtiger
weise finanzminister scholz sehr darauf
gedrängt hat dass wir klare zielvorgaben
machen das entstehen soll und dafür
klare regeln da sind dann haben wir ins
gesetz den ländern den auftrag gegeben
diese zu verwalten und zu zuweisen und
ich müsste auch im föderalen miteinander
von bund und ländern davon ausgehen
können und dürfen das wenn länder
investitionszuschüsse ausreichen
gefunden sind an bestimmte bedingungen
bis hin dass wir eine debatte hatten
lokal oder high care und wir sehr gut
klar gesagt haben high care also höherer
standard an intensivbetten ausstattung
dass dann die vom bund über die länder
verwalteten und zugewiesenen mittel dann
eben auch ordnungsgemäß verwaltet und
zugewiesen werden so ist das in der
föderalen struktur übrigens nicht nur in
der pandemie sondern grundsätzlich dass
nicht wenige förderprogramme daneben
auch über die länder in der verwaltung
umgesetzt werden und deswegen kann und
soll das alles natürlich auch nach
gehalten und mit transparenz versehen
werden und das wird es zug um zug der
bundesrechnungshof erkennt im übrigen ja
auch an dass in einer pandemischen
notsituation eben auch zügig hat
gehandelt werden müssen wenn ich genau
gelesen habe nach einer nachfrage an
haben wie lange noch
in dem bericht des rechnungshofes auch
von einem schreiben des lka an das
gesundheitsministerium vom 11 januar
diesen jahres die rede wo es darum geht
dass sie sagen dass manche kliniken
möglicherweise künstlich niedrige zahlen
von intensivbetten melden um an
zuschüsse zu kommen sie berichten davon
mehreren e mails und telefonanrufen
dieses el-kaida- bekommen hat dann zieht
es ungefähr quantifizieren um wie viel
ihrer einschätzung nach die intensiv die
freie intensivbetten zahl künstlich nach
unten gerechnet worden ist also da muss
ich zunächst mal sagen dass ich weder
den bericht des rechnungshofs können
noch
mich jetzt an einen bericht erinnern
kann werden wir prüfen können wir gerne
nachliefern
aber momentan bin ich dazu die sprache
fällt dann will ich zwei fragen
einwerfen online die sich jetzt auch mit
dem rechnungshof berichte beschäftigen
und damit geld ist eine von herrn wegner
von dpa der rechnungshof wirft dem
ministerium bei masken für
risikopatienten überhöhte erstattung an
apotheken vor bedauern sie dass ihr haus
bei der balance zwischen pragmatismus
und genauigkeit in der krise im
vergangenen jahr nicht doch öfters sich
mehr zeit gelassen hat und die zweite
folge von den eugh vom handelsblatt zum
impfen auf weiß warum kann man bei hat
man bei der vergütung der apotheken und
ärzte bei fremden impfling das auf 18
euro festgesetzt und steht entsteht bei
den ärzten nicht so die gefahr dass sich
die ärzte bewusst fremde patienten zur
ausstellung des imf nach preise suchen
oder ihre patienten zu befreundeten
ärzten schicken
also zuerst einmal die frage des hätten
wir uns mehr zeit lassen sollen
es ist als hätte ich mir letztes jahr im
märz mehr zeit lassen sollen masken zu
beschaffen
möglicherweise werden da manche dinge
nicht so wie sie heute sind und
kritisiert werden aber wenn mich
ärztliche direktorin von unikliniken
anrufen und sagen ja sparen wenn ich
nächste woche nicht masken auf dem tisch
habe im krankenhaus dann stelle ich hier
den betrieb ein
dann kann ich nicht drüber nachdenken ob
ich noch zeit habe vier wochen die
rahmenbedingungen zu schenken
das jedenfalls sehe ich als
bundesminister für gesundheit als
oberste aufgabe an in einer solchen
situation zu helfen dass kliniken nicht
ihren betrieb einstellen und zu der
frage der schutzmasken um die es in dem
bundesrechnungshof bericht geht es gab
einen beschluss der ministerpräsidenten
mit der bundesregierung das besonders
verwundbare gruppen vor weihnachten im
dezember schutzmasken erhalten sollen
nicht zuletzt für auch die
weihnachtstage
also gab es tatsächlich ein zeitlicher
dränge dringlichkeit das umzusetzen
und wenn sie sich dann überlegen wie
kriegst du denn das eigentlich hin
in einem land das leider immer noch
keine digitale identität für seine
bürger
hat und wo die bundesregierung wie
übrigens auch keine landesregierung die
chance hat die bürgerinnen und bürger
direkt zu adressieren im wahrsten sinne
des wortes weil wir überhaupt keinen
zugriff haben auf irgendwelche
meldeadresse oder sonst was da wie
kriegen wir es hin innerhalb von zwei
drei wochen einer gruppe die schon bei
beschluss der ministerpräsidenten
erwarte deutlich über 20 millionen
menschen liegen würde alleine wegen der
altersstruktur in deutschland möglichst
schnell zu versorgen sind wir
tatsächlich auf dem weg gekommen und ich
bin dankbar dass die apotheken
mitgegangen sind dass wir gesagt haben
das machen wir über die apotheken die
beschaffen diese masten in eigener
verantwortung und sind bereit sie auch
sehr pragmatisch auszugeben für die
phase vor weihnachten und dann in der
phase nach weihnachten haben wir es ja
auch mit entsprechenden nachweisen
gemacht und ich kann ihnen nur sagen
ende november anfang dezember als diese
entscheidung anstand waren wir nicht
sicher lässt sich halt heute immer alles
anders bewerten ja heute gibt es fsb
zwei masken seit und genug wir waren
damals nicht sicher ob es überhaupt
genug verfügbare schutzmasken gibt in
einer größenordnung von 400 millionen
masken plusminus die wir brauchen würden
wenn man diesen fallen sozusagen diese
vor 15 schutzmasken pro person zur
verfügung stellen will
es haben einige leute angezweifelt ob
der weltmarkt das überhaupt hergibt weil
das meer war als europa da
in zwei drei monaten abgefordert hat wir
waren also in einer situation wo wir
nicht abschließend sicher sein konnten
ob überhaupt in kurzer zeit eine
ausreichende menge zur verfügung steht
und ja im nachhinein im rückblick hätte
ich hätten wir ich sage noch einmal eine
verordnung des bundesministeriums ist
nie eine verordnung die wir alleine
machen die schutzmasken verordnung ist
sogar ausdrücklich nach gesetz im
einvernehmen
ich will dass man rechtlich übersetzen
das heißt es geht nur mit ausdrücklicher
zustimmung des finanzministeriums
erstellt worden weil wir eben gemeinsam
in der damaligen lage zu dieser
einschätzung gekommen sind zu der ich
gerade gekommen bin
klar wenn mehr zeit gewesen wäre und
wenn ich wissen dass ich möglicherweise
schon sechs wochen später hatte schon
sechs wochen früher gehabt hätte hätte
man manches anders gemacht das ist so
das kann nicht konstatieren ist kann
nicht zugestehen ohne zweifel
nur wenn die ansage ist vor weihnachten
sollen schutzmasken ankommen dann habe
ich halt nicht sechs wochen zeit sondern
dann müssen wir sehen wie vor
weihnachten schutzmasken ankommen er war
noch die zweite frage nach der
verdrängung also die frage wer jetzt ist
halt wieder die frage was was trauen wir
den ärzten zu und was sozusagen trauen
wir ihn zu gehen wir davon aus dass
heilberufler ärztinnen und ärzte
regelhaft sich in einer solchen pandemie
situation so verhalten dass jeder zu
seinem nachbar praxis seine patienten
schickt und der sich dann von sich von
dem seien die anderen patienten schicken
lässt um mehr abrechnen zu können ist
das unser bild von ärzten und herzen in
deutschland und muss deswegen da eine
extra kontrolle geben oder ist unser
bild das das ärztinnen und ärzte wie
auch apothekerinnen und apotheker in
dieser pandemie ein großer mehrheit sehr
verantwortungsvoll handelt das ist eine
grundsatzfrage die wir uns als
gesellschaft in der pony stellen müssen
die wir uns im bundesministerium für
gesundheit stellen müssen
wir gehen aber nach den erfahrungen die
wir einfach haben auch aus dieser
pandemie davon aus dass dort sehr
verrannt
öffentlich gehandelt werden wird
kollegin dann in der reihenfolge der
mitte fahren weiter und dann kommen so
spiekermann und dann lege ich hätte eine
frage zur globalen impfstoff verteilung
vielleicht kann sie sagen wie sieht denn
der deutsche beitrag zur versorgung
ärmere länder insgesamt aus dort hat es
auswirkungen auf die in deutschland
verfügbare impfstoff menge zuerst was so
kovacs angeht es gibt jetzt zwei dinge
dass eine finanzierung das andere sind
dosen was kovacs angeht stand der ich
habe jetzt die zahlen von etwa zehn
tagen im kopf die finanzierungszusagen
die andere länder seitdem gegeben haben
kann ich jetzt nicht berücksichtigen war
es so dass eine von fünf impfdosen die
über kovacs weltweit finanziert werden
aus deutschland finanziert werden eine
von fünf sind der zweitgrößte geldgeber
und übernehmen damit wie wenige andere
länder eine verantwortung für die welt
aus humanitären gründen aber auch aus
eigenen nationalen interesse weil wir
interesse daran haben dass die welt
schnell geimpft ist etwa mit blick auf
mutationen und anderes mehr
das ist der finanzielle beitrag den wir
leisten
der andere beitrag ist das abgeben von
dosen wo wir uns ja im rahmen der
europäischen union die frau
bundeskanzlerin für uns für die
bundesrepublik für die bundesregierung
ja auch angekündigt hat 30 millionen
dosen in die 100 millionen der eu also
frankreich 30 millionen deutschland 30
millionen zeigt dass diese beiden
staaten im tandem auch einen großen teil
der eu zusage
hier erfüllen werden und wir natürlich
grundsätzlich bereit sind auch in
abhängigkeit von unserer impfkampagne
darüber hinaus weitere dosen zur
verfügung zu stellen
aber wir müssen die richtige balance
finden gerade in dieser phase der
impfkampagne und der pandemie meine
erfahrung ist sie haben eine höhere
akzeptanz dafür auch in der welt zu
helfen wenn zu hause die dinge beim
impfen nehmen auch gut laufen und
deswegen geht es um die richtige balance
und die richtigen zeitpunkt
wir engagieren uns finanziell und wir
engagieren uns und werden uns auch noch
stärker engagieren
in der zahl der dosen die wir direkt zur
verfügung stellen und drittens dafür
weicher als teil der delegation von
präsident marc rauch mit in südafrika
und wir werden unterstützen das
entstehen von produktionsstätten und
kapazitäten auch in anderen teilen der
welt insbesondere in afrika können sie
das finanzielle engagement mit sie
fanden
bevor ich jetzt ich hätte einen kopf
aber ich bin mir nicht 100 prozent
sicher dürfen wir ihnen die nachliefern
die summe die wir zu kovacs beitragen
ich habe doch noch eine frage vom
bundesrechnungshof
unterstützungsleistung aus ihrem haus
nach dem gießkannenprinzip das ja also
klingt ja nicht nach differenzierter
geldausgabe und die andere frage ist
warum sie gestern bei der debatte im
bundestag in einer aktuellen stunde habe
ich nicht in die debatte eingeschaltet
haben sondern zuschauer rolle
eingenommen haben sie hätten ja
möglicherweise zur aufklärung beitragen
können zum ersten ist das was ich zum
bericht des bundesrechnungshofes der im
übrigen tatbestände aufgreift die alle
schon beschrieben worden sind also jetzt
nichts neues macht nicht per se besser
oder schlechter aber es ist jetzt nichts
neues in diesem bericht drin
in wahrheit alles themen die wir schon
miteinander diskutiert haben auch hier
schon diskutiert haben in der
bundespressekonferenz
aber es ist sind gut vor allem das ist
das ist das was ich aus diesem
bundesrechnungshof und kommt übrigens
nächste woche wahrscheinlich noch einer
zu den masten beschaffungen insgesamt
dennis der haushaltsausschuss hat
übrigens weil das immer wieder ja auch
gesagt wird der bundesrechnungshof
sollte auch die masken beschaffungen
prüfen
das macht der bundesrechnungshof auf
antrag des haushaltsausschusses seit
dezember glaube ich oder november bei
uns doch dazu wird es im bericht geben
und was ich wichtig finde an diesen
berichten ich habe das übrigens
ausdrücklich unterstützt
im haushaltsausschuss als gute idee
warum weil es doch die einzige weg ist
zu lernen also mein haus unser haus
unser ministerium ist ein gesetzgebungs
ministerium was wir machen
seit jahren jahrzehnten ist gesetze als
wir nicht so häufig machen ist operativ
arbeiten
das ist nicht das bundesministerium für
gesundheit
was wir aber lernen in dieser pandemie
in einer pandemie muss ein
gesundheitsministerium auch stärker
operative einheiten haben deswegen wird
es eine debatte brauchen ich hab mit
innenminister seehofer gestern
vorgestern noch darüber gesprochen dass
wir reden wollen über die frage wie gpk
bevölkerung ausgesprochen bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz ohne das bbk das lka
wie wir strukturen vernetzt bauen mit
den institutionen die wir haben für die
nächste pandemie und genauso wichtig ist
es doch aus einem rechnungshofbericht zu
lernen erkenntnisse zu ziehen
miteinander wie in einer situation wo
die regulären beschaffungswege und die
haben wir ja erst versucht beschaffungs
ämter zu beauftragen amtshilfe und die
nicht funktionieren was ist eigentlich
der richtige weg ist welche wege nicht
so gut funktioniert haben und welche
wege besser funktioniert habe das kann
man ja nur lernen indem es eben im nach
blick noch mal betrachtet wird und dafür
finde ich die bundesrechnungshof
berichte sehr sehr hilfreich um einfach
für eine nächste pandemie also können
wir alles bei der nächsten pandemie
berücksichtigen wenn man nicht unter
zeitdruck schnell handeln muss um
menschenleben zu retten um zu vermeiden
dass kliniken den betrieb einstellen
sondern in ruhe sich über berichte
beugen kann und zu lernen für die
zukunft kann ich das nur gut finden wenn
man noch die zweite frage war also habe
ich habe mich gestern in dieser debatte
eingemischt und zwar gleich zweimal
mehrere stunden einmal im ausschuss für
gesundheit und einmal im ausschuss im
haushaltsausschuss und mein eindruck ist
dass die debatte in beiden ausschüssen
deutlich inhaltlicher in der tiefe und
in der sachfrage war als das
möglicherweise in der öffentlichen
debatte bisher stellenweise gelungen ist
wir haben sehr sehr gut auf
klären informieren können über den
standard cp ca
die unterschiede über die prüfkriterien
über die zeitlichen abläufe die es
gegeben hat über all diese fragen
insofern habe ich mich den diskussionen
in den ausschüssen gestellt auch gerne
gestellt woran ich mich nicht beteiligen
möchte in dieser phase der pandemie
weiter
wir sind noch mitten in der pandemie wir
haben echt grad eine gute entwicklung
aber professor wähler hat darauf
hingewiesen dass ist jetzt hier noch
nicht vorbei alles und ich kann dem
auseinandersetzung die nicht in der
sache getragen sind im moment wenig
abgewinnen ich möchte einfach meine
arbeit machen wir machen jetzt weiter
herr kollege dann jessen dann ja kein
herr professor herr sparen
sie haben gesagt die zahlen gehen runter
allerdings sind sie höher als vor einem
jahr um die zeit morgen beginnt die
fußball europameisterschaft in wie fern
halten sie public viewing events für
vertretbar und unter welchen maßnahmen
na ja wir haben diese regeln und
vorstellungen die wir seit mehr als
einem jahr in unserer empfehlung geben
die haben sich ja nicht geändert
das heißt also wir haben konzepte wo wir
ein kontroll cupid konzept das haben wir
im februar diesen jahres erstmals
publiziert wenn dann genügend evidenzen
hatten für die vorgaben wir haben wir
sagen ganz klar es gibt bestimmte
obergrenzen für veranstaltungen abhängig
von den entsprechenden indikator und für
uns ist eigentlich die grandi ka tor
die inzidenz die andere wichtige
indikator ist die belegung der
intensivbetten und abhängig davon kann
man dann solche events stattfinden
lassen oder nicht was aber eben in der
verantwortung der entsprechenden lokalen
behörden liegt das ist der plan den wir
vorgeben
wir wissen dass das virus noch nicht da
ist und darum ist es gerade wichtig dass
man diese basismaßnahmen weiter herrlich
also das was wir wirklich in den letzten
monaten denke ich auch sehr stark
verinnerlicht haben und wo sich wirklich
sehr sehr viele menschen dran halten in
seinem land das man abstand hält
wenn es nicht anders geht wenn es
möglich ist dass man diese hygiene
einhält und vor allen dingen das tragen
von mund nasenschutz oder von masken
oder von von ng2 marx insbesondere und
nasenschutz das hat einen hohen effekt
und wir kriegen ja immer mehr evidenz
dafür auch also die publikations lage
bessert sie immer das heißt also es gibt
situationen unter dem man einen
bestimmten anzahl von menschen das
ermöglichen kann
das hängt ab von diesen parametern und
es wird letztlich entschieden von den
behörden vor ort wir müssen immer wieder
darauf hinweisen dass eben das virus
durch mobilität natürlich getragen wird
und wir sind prinzipiell immer
vorsichtig und zurückhaltend wir möchten
nicht dass die zahlen durch solche
events natürlich wieder steigen das ist
ganz klar
also ich kann mich da grundsätzlich
anschließen ich meine ich nun meine
münsterländische heimat ich habe eine
vorstellung davon wie public viewing im
garten als public jungen haben
öffentliche plätze vor augen aber ich
weiß ja auch wie es sonst so
wahrscheinlich mein stammtisch zu hause
hand haben würde
in normalen zeiten und insofern ist
entscheidend am ende das was insgesamt
entscheidend ist draußen abstand
vielleicht idealerweise geimpft oder
getestet alle beteiligten und auch wenn
es vielleicht schwer fällt insbesondere
wenn es freude oder weniger freude gibt
alkohol macht per se nachlässiger was
angeht vielleicht etwas weniger alkohol
ist auch gesünder nachfrage schauen sie
selbst die europameisterschaft und wo
wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein soll hatte
ich nicht mehr auf dem schirm das ist
morgen losgeht vor lauter anderen dingen
die mich diese woche schon beschäftigt
haben
aber morgen abend klappt es vielleicht
herr minister sparen sie haben eben am
beispiel der anrufenden klinikdirektoren
bei der masken beschaffung anschaulich
dargelegt welche rolle auch so
persönlich
die direkte eindrücke bei
entscheidungsprozessen haben das erlaube
ich mir jetzt auch mal ich habe vor
wenigen tagen mit den betreibern einer
privaten teststation längere zeit
gesprochen und die haben gesagt das wort
an allen ecken und enden betrogen wird
das hätten wir euch auch sagen können
drei wochen bevor das im fernsehen
aufgedeckt wurde als wir die test
verordnung wir betreiber des verordnung
gelesen haben haben wir gesagt das ist
eine einladung zum betrug
wir können bis heute nicht
nachvollziehen warum auf jegliche form
der intensiven kontrolle und
nachweispflicht durchgeführter test
verzichtet wurde
wie nehmen sie solche kritik auf was
haben sie da eigentlich bei der
erstellung der test verordnung falsch
gemacht oder unterlassen
also zuerst einmal ist es ja tatsächlich
so dass wir vereinbart hatten
auch zwischen finanz- und
gesundheitsministerium dass wir uns im
juni anschauen sowohl was die marktlage
die preislage angeht aber auch insgesamt
die entwicklung bei den test stellen um
daraus schlüsse zu ziehen und die test
verordnung zu überarbeiten im nachhinein
hätte man das besser vier wochen feuer
gemacht
oder 6 aber es war eben vor allem dem
wunsch dem willen geschuldet sehr
pragmatisch das zu machen um kurzfristig
auch die test infrastruktur entstehen zu
lassen die in der dritten welle erster
sicherheit gibt und zwar ins dann auch
öffnung schritte möglich macht und so
ist es ja also ich weiß noch wenn wir
schon bei anekdotischen berichten
sozusagen sind als ich vingst sonntag
durch berlin radelte stand vor jeder
test stelle an der ich vorbei radelte
eine schlange also ist ja nicht so dass
ich mir halt finde ich in dieser debatte
das richtig gewichten
es betrug gegeben oder gibt betrug und
auch missbrauch und schwarze schafe aber
es hat auch viele gegeben die ein
angebot gemacht haben das von millionen
deutschen jeden tag genutzt worden ist
und noch wird und das in sicherheit
gegeben hat und gibt für den alltag und
damit in der struktur ist die auch weil
sie schnell entstehen sollte wie gesagt
in dieser dritten welle entsprechend
dann
da gelegt worden ist aber es gibt ein
zwei dinge im nachhinein zum beispiel
wäre ich nie auf die idee gekommen sag
ich ganz ehrlich dass in dem umfang der
allgemeinverfügungen beauftragungen
stattfinden also das ganze bundesländer
sagen wir beauftragen nicht in dem der
einzelne so zu sagen es ist kann ja
niemand sich zur textstelle erklären
muss ja beauftragt seien durch die
zuständige behörde und der weitere
anbieter so steht es in der verordnung
soll eine ordnungsgemäße durchführung
garantieren
und das bedeutet doch für mich dass die
zuständige behörde sich anschaut
ob den derjenige den sie beauftragt das
kann den räumlichkeiten her von den
hygiene von den abläufen her wenn man es
natürlich per allgemeinverfügung macht
allgemeinverfügung heißt ja für ein
bundesland zu sagen herr folgende
parameter erfüllt kann loslegen ohne
sich irgendwas konkret im einzelnen
anzuschauen
das jedenfalls haben wir so nicht
erwartet
das ist wahr deswegen jetzt das so nicht
mehr geben können und alle die per
allgemeinverfügung zugelassen sind nach
einer übergangsphase dann auch nicht
mehr zugelassen und beauftragt sein muss
jetzt eine einzelbetrachtung dann auch
geben und das andere ist das thema der
abrechnung die abrechnungs begründen
unterlagen sind aufzubewahren und zb die
der auftrag sozusagen auch die
unterschrift die man ja braucht bei
einer entsprechenden testung des
getesteten die sind aufzubewahren
die unterlagen offenkundig ist noch mehr
kontrolle der abrechnungs begründen
unterlagen notwendig und auch
stichprobenartig und auf plausibilität
und auch das bilden bilden wir ab und
auch da sage ich ja mit dem wissen von
heute würde man manche regelungen anders
gestalten
das eigentliche ziel eine schnell
erreichbare erstmal schnell aber auch
eine gut erreichbare flächen der test
infrastruktur aufzubauen ist aber eben
tatsächlich auch erreicht worden
und ich habe gestern im
haushaltsausschuss für die vorbereitung
auf den haushaltsausschuss und noch mal
geschaut
ich habe mich an das hier nicht mit ich
glaube es war am 21
februar gab es diese berühmte
kabinettssitzung über die sie
anschließend
auch nachvollziehbarer weise alle
berichtet haben weil da der erste märz
nach hinten geschoben worden ist als
staat beginnen und für diese
kabinettssitzung gab es zwischen olaf
scholz und mehr vereinbart eine vorlage
und in dieser vorlage steht drin dass
wir mit monatlichen kosten rechnen von
500 bis 800 millionen euro weil wir
einfach die zahlen der täglichen testung
die österreich zum beispiel ja auch
österreich hat ja so ein angebot
dänemark auch vom bürger test schon vor
uns gehabt und wir haben einfach
hochgerechnet aus den erfahrungen
österreichs was bedeutet das für
deutschland wenn es endlich in anspruch
genommen wird
wir legen jedenfalls deutlich unter
diesen monatlichen kosten bisher 660
millionen euro die erwähnt wurden als
letzter ab rechnungssumme sind eine
wahnsinnig große summe geld wahnsinnig
viel geld geteilt durch die test kosten
sind es aber 40 bis 50 millionen tests
und 40 bis 50 millionen tests bei 80
millionen einwohnern innerhalb von vier
bis sechs wochen abrechnungs zeit ist
jetzt für mich auch kein phänomen wo ich
sagen muss dass die zahlen völlig und
nachvollziehbar wären die dort den
abrechnung gebracht worden sind zumal
diese summe nicht nur die bürger tests
enthalten sondern auch die tests in
anderen bereich der rationalen kern
dieser kritik von betreiberseite war ja
dass sie sagen wir begreifen dass bis
heute nicht warum so zu sagen uns die
möglichkeit gegeben wurde dinge in
rechnung zu stellen ohne sie nachweisen
zu müssen
das ist ja sie sagen jetzt muss ja
aufbewahrt werden sozusagen
nachgelagerte stichprobenartige
kontrolle
aber warum was war der grund dafür zu
sagen ihr könnt einreichen wie erstatten
ohne dass es einen nachweis der
tatsächlich angefallenen kosten
die zahlen im verfahren gibt wie kommt
man auf eine solche unterlassungs ich
mal wie kann das zustandekommen kann ich
ihnen sagen wir hatten ja zuerst im
fokus und eigentlich auch als haupt
adressaten die ärztinnen und ärzte die
apotheken und die rettungsorganisation
drk und andere die viele textstellen
betrieben haben
bei einrichtungen wie diesen ist eine
regelung die sagt etwa wenn sachkosten
bis zu sechs euro steht da ja auch
deswegen ist sozusagen das was
gelegentlich gesagt wird es würde immer
18 euro kosten ja nicht per se richtig
sondern nach verordnung jedenfalls nach
nachgewiesenen sachkosten bis zu sechs
euro für den test bei diesen
institutionen ist es nicht ungewöhnlich
auch solche mechanismen zu haben das
sozusagen die abrechnungs begründen
unterlagen aufzubewahren sind sieben
nachhinein geprüft werden können und
damit auch eine hohes maß von
verantwortung in der ordnungsgemäßen
abrechnung einhergeht
die herausforderung ist ja insbesondere
nur aber insbesondere bei den weiter so
genannten weiteren anbietern privaten
anbietern
doch da gibt es solche und solche mit
ist ganz wichtig dass wir nicht alle
über einen kamm scheren
und ich will auch darüber berichten ich
mich ja ministerpräsidenten persönlich
angerufen und gesagt herr spahn wir
hatten feuer nicht so umfassend in der
test verordnung vor dem achten mehr als
in der fassung wenn sie da mal
reinschauen
die die feier gültig war waren die
weiteren anbieter deutlich eingeschränkt
in der frage wer das überhaupt sagen
kann und dann haben wir viele
rückmeldungen aus den bundesländern
gekriegt bis hin zum ministerpräsidenten
die gesagt haben wir sparen wenn sie das
nicht deutlich weiter dass wir deutlich
andere auch beauftragen können dann
werden wir die tests infrastruktur nicht
zügig ausbauen können ich weiß noch wie
richtigerweise olaf scholz und corona
kabinett gesagt hat da steht doch jetzt
viel gastronomie leer viele
räumlichkeiten viele gastronomen haben
eigentlich personal das gerade leider
nicht so viel zu tun hat weil
beschlossen
wer ist denn ich eigentlich gut wenn
auch in vielen dieser gastronomischen
einrichtungen test stellen entstehen
könnten lasst uns doch sehen dass wir
möglichst viele
stellen entstehen lassen weitere
anbieter haben und offenkundig ist der
mechanismus der im gesundheitswesen gut
weil verlässlich und auch besser erprobt
funktioniert und besser nachvollziehbar
in dem bereich nicht der richtige der
beste ansatz gewesen muss man ja im
nachhinein sagen und deswegen werden wir
das jetzt eben auch verändern herr klein
aber das interesse daran das ist mir
aber noch mal wichtig gewesen dass es
weitere anbieter gibt und einen
schnellen aufbau einer test
infrastruktur ist sehr nachdrücklich
auch und gerade aus den ländern
vorgebracht wird nochmal zum
intensivbetten komplex herr minister
wann wussten sie dann nicht ganz genau
dass krankenhäuser bei der angabe der
zahl der freien intensivbetten
manipulieren und war die entscheidung
für den block down dann rückblickend
betrachtet überhaupt richtig lang zu
hart was vielleicht ganz falsch also das
ist ja erstmal ein bisher im raum
stehende vorwurf der manipulation
da gab es glaube ich ja und ob die
veröffentlichung eines papieres die zeit
vergeht zwischen 11 34 wochen auch eine
diskussion rund um das sogenannte die
wie register also das intensiv register
und das was sich abbildet und nach
meinem eindruck haben auch viele der
vorwürfe die vorgebracht worden sind
entkräftet werden können fachlich von
denjenigen auch die das intensiv
register betreiben aber wissen sie jeder
gerne intensiv station besucht hat in
dieser zeit oder gesprochen hat mit
intensivmedizinern hat doch gesehen dass
wir keine abstrakte debatte darüber
führen ob unsere intensivstation
belastet sind oder dass das eine
abstrakte debatte ist ob intensiv
pflegekräfte gerade am ende ihrer kräfte
sind das war sehr konkret schon einige
hundert meter von hier in der charité
die übrigens jetzt noch relativ viele
patienten hat weil sie für berlin das
zentrale hauptsächlich jetzt noch macht
die intensivstationen waren voll und sie
waren sehr belastet die dort
beschäftigten durch cupid 19 daran gibt
es nun wirklich nichts zu deuteln
was die frage angeht so zu sagen welche
intensivbetten gezählt werden
register das ist im übrigen vor dieser
pandemie gar nicht gab
das ist ja auch etwas wo wir gerade im
gespräch mit der intensivmedizinischen
verbänden die wir so was dauerhaft jetzt
installieren und immer besser machen
denn seine aussage kraft die debatte
gibt es bis jetzt ist aber vor allem der
vorwurf der manipulation im raum der
sich jedenfalls als flächendeckendes
phänomen nicht mehr jedenfalls bekannt
erhärtet hat dem rechnungshofbericht sie
hatten folge 6 wir haben viel gelernt
jetzt noch mal dass ich lerne zwischen 6
euro und einen euro 62 ist eine ganz
schöne differenz wie sind sie denn
damals auf diesen preis bekommen und was
lernen sie daraus und jetzt auch noch
mal zu den intensivbetten hermann jetzt
davon ausgehen dass diese zahlen jetzt
auch stimmen wieder angegeben werden
oder wurden wie vieh vorgeworfen falsche
anreize gesetzt
also zuerst einmal was die apotheken
angeht müssen wir mal sehen das klingt
immer noch wenig ist aber bei 19 prozent
nicht wenig die umsatzsteuer ist
inklusive
das ist schon eher richtung 5 euro was
immer noch im rückblick und insbesondere
natürlich in der späteren marktsituation
im verlaufe dieses jahres dann deswegen
weil sie auch reduziert im übrigen ja
dann was mit hineinkommt ist die
beschaffungs situation also selbst zu
beschaffen und das war im dezember
die herausforderung ist ja ich muss mich
selbst auch immer wieder erinnern und
gelegentlich in meiner aufzeichnung
schauen weil mit stand heute man sich
die frage stellen warum haben wir
eigentlich november so entschieden
im november war die weltlage ende
november anfang dezember als diese
verordnung an stand das sp2 man geht
einfach noch eine völlig andere
es gab schon verbesserung im vergleich
zu vor drei monaten vorher aber es gab
auch noch nicht das phänomen das wir
heute haben dass die irgendwie discount
dafür ich weiß gar nicht was im moment
deutlich unter einem euro teilweise
heute morgen im radio gehört auf dem weg
hierhin von einem drogerie anbieter
selbst test für 95 cent in der werbung
also vor vor vor acht wochen hat der
drogerie anbieter mir noch geschworen
der pricing niemals 102 euro weil der
einkauf und überhaupt und sowieso
wettbewerb hilft marktinstrumente zu
nutzen hilft deswegen hab ich übrigens
gerade beim thema testen immer gesagt
der markt wird das relativ schnell
richten als da erinnere ich mich noch
sehr gut wir haben ja schon ein paar
debatten miteinander hinter uns rund ums
testen alle gesagt haben
da muss man aber doch bis hin zu task
forces ganz anders mit umso jetzt
nochmal zu den masken der damalige
marktsituation in der weltweiten
marktsituation und in dem volumen um das
es ging mir ging es nicht um 10
millionen masken uns hier ging es um 15
masken für 20 bis 30 millionen deutsche
jeweils in einem volumen dass so wenige
länder auf der welt bisher innerhalb
weniger wochen abgefragt hatten wollten
wir sicherstellen dass diese masken am
ende auch da sind weil ich mir
vorgestellt hab was macht das eigentlich
mit den deutschen und vor allem mit dem
besonders schutzbedürftigen wenn die
bundesregierung sagt wir ständig etwas
p2 massen zur verfügung sie gehen dann
in die apotheke aber dann gibt es keine
es wäre das denn eigentlich für eine
debatte geworden
von leuten die gesagt haben für
weihnachten und und die zeit hätten wir
aber eigentlich erwartet dass wenn die
bundesregierung gesagt dass es masken
gibt es welche gibt
und da mussten wir abwägen und das ist
eben das ergebnis der abwägung da
gewesen übrigens was die gesamten kosten
angeht wir haben kalkuliert mal mit 2,5
milliarden euro steht ja auch im
haushalt dann kam hinzu etwa 5 millionen
hartz-iv-bezieher die in diesen
zweieinhalb milliarden euro noch gar
nicht drin kalkuliert sein konnten weil
es hat sich ja später ergeben dass wir
auch dort was übrigens zeigt dass es nie
um verteilung aus eigenem bestand an
hartz 4 empfängern gegen ein gesetz
einer anderen debatte die wir gerade
haben aber unabhängig davon sind also 5
millionen bezugsberechtigten
dazugekommen und trotzdem liegen wir bei
den gesamtkosten bei gut 2 milliarden
nicht bei 2,5 mehr als 2,11 glaube ich
wir liegen unter den veranschlagten
gesamtkosten wir haben die leute gut
versorgt wie
sogar fünf millionen mehr versorgt als
eigentlich geplant war hätte man im
nachhinein früher die preise reduzieren
können im nachhinein ja damals aber mit
dem hohen risiko dass dann die masten
nicht vollumfänglich verfügbar sind und
das risiko wollte ich nicht eingehen
dann habe ich jetzt jede menge unseren
betten entschuldigung zu den betten sind
die anzahl der intensivbetten die da
angegeben sind ist es jetzt die richtige
zeit wieder angegeben wird in dem
register das ist das was die in das
register wird der betrieben maßgeblich
von den intensivmedizinern selbst dem
die dem verband der intensivmediziner
zusammen mit dem robert-koch-institut
ich bin herr professor wieder sagen ganz
so der frage aber in der stelle
grundsätzlich das intensivmediziner in
dieses register hinein das melden was
tatsächlich an gibt es auch
unterschiedliche kategorien sofort
verfügbar in 24 stunden verfügbar
sozusagen nach etwas längerer frist und
verfügbar wenn man in not wäre und also
ich unterstelle dass das schon auch von
intensivmedizinern ärztinnen und ärzten
korrekt angegeben wird
ja also vielleicht nochmal zu diesem
thema weil es ein sehr komplexes thema
ist wir werden in kürze dazu auch eine
publikation noch mal auflegen wo diese
dinge komplex da diese komplexen dinge
dargestellt werden man muss bei
intensivbetten unterscheiden es gibt ja
auch intensivbetten mit oder ohne bart
muss gibt verschiedene beatmung saßen
das ist nicht so trivial das wirklich
auseinander zeit und das zweite was in
der in der debatte oft auch glaube ich
nicht oder zumindest nicht genügend
beachtet wird ist die tatsache dass das
reine vorhandensein eines bettes und
auch von entsprechenden gerätschaften
wie zum beispiel beatmungsgerät oder
diese eck wo diese künstliche lunge wie
wir das sagen
das ist der eine teil aber der andere
teil ist dann eben das personal das
diese betten betreibt und insofern sind
das natürlich immer vorgänge die auch
teilweise tagesaktuell sehr stark
schwanken
und wir werden das noch einmal darlegen
um die problematik darzulegen wir haben
ja auch
ich meine ich bin nach wie vor extrem
stolz dass wir so ein register überhaupt
geschaffen haben ich glaube zwar nicht
april oder waren das war das war ja
schon vor einem jahr
und wenn man so ein neues register
schafft dann haben wir auch mehrfach
nachgeschärft das weiß ich auch noch
aber das werden wir alles nochmal
darlegen und ich habe ich habe keinen
zweifel dass die zahlen natürlich
korrekt sind vor allen dingen möchte ich
dem diesem diesem vorwurf der jetzt
vielleicht im raum steht den den ich
ihre frage zum beispiel genommen habe
dass so was wie eine überlastung dieser
station vielleicht gar nicht aber das
finde ich sehr zynisch muss ich wirklich
sagen die wir hatten doch hier den
intensivpfleger einmal in unserer
pressekonferenz reden sie doch mit den
menschen die diese intensivstation
betrieben haben und doch geht es um
leben und tod das sind menschen die mit
einem coolen arbeitsethos in einer krise
extrem hoch belastet worden
und wir schauen uns diese ganzen daten
an wir werden das noch einmal darlegen
und ich glaube dann sollte man die
debatte noch mal führen
wir erwarten natürlich dass
krankenhausbetreiber und die menschen
die in dem system unterwegs sind und
verantwortung tragen dass die natürlich
auch mit mit korrekten zahlen umgehen
das ist ja klar
insofern muss ich dann wohl leider
diesen bericht des rechnungshofs
nächsten fünf das ich kenne aber wie
minister sparen sagt wir lernen ständig
dazu und wir müssen vor allen dingen
transparent und offen diese dinge
diskutieren wie wir sehr daran gelegen
dass dieses register weitergeführt wird
und je besser es ist sie genau es ist
desto mehr hilft es uns denn es geht ja
immer wieder um quantifizierung von
leistungen quantifizierung von systemen
das brauchen wir einen ganzen medizin
das ist ein gutes modell und das sollten
wir verbessern und weiterführen wollte
kurz habe eine entsetzt wir sind der
zweitgrößte geldgeber beim fct also dem
instrument der vero und eine milliarde
euro davon gehen in kovacs wir haben
noch knapp zehn minuten ich habe noch
jede fall bringen fragen online
lediglich mal ein paar grad einwerfen
edsel ford focus fragt wird eine
hydrologe impfung
astrazeneca zweitimpfung m rna im eu
ausland anerkannt gab es darüber
gespräche der eu
herr kreis von golem.de fragt gibt es
einschränkungen verdi to sap einsetzen
darf sascha meyer von dpa fragt ein
handballfeld deutschland mit anderen eu
bürgern werden alle impfstoffe
akzeptiert reicht auch schon erstimpfung
und zum beispiel zu restaurants und
kultureinrichtung zu bekommen wer viel
auf einmal also zuerst einmal eu hetero-
logi impfungen das ist tatsächlich
bestandteil von gespräch das eine
herausforderung ist übrigens auch bei
der definition von genesen dass wir
leider anders als man sich wünschen
würde noch keine europäische ein
europäische unions einheitliche
definition in manchen bereichen haben
das gilt auch für theologie impfung das
wichtige an dem kopf das ist er
dokumentiert den vollen impfschutz so
dass da gar keine debatte darüber da
sind ob der deal entstanden ist durch
astra astra oder biontech piontek oder
astra piontek der volle impfschutz wird
dokumentiert und damit ist das dann da
auch hinterlegt die frage der prüfer
können sie vielleicht was zu sagen würde
man jetzt sagen ich richtig informiert
bin
gilt das für alle dass die alle
runterladen können wofür open source
kann durch verschiedene institutionen
genutzt werde ich den auch unterlagen
und ihr zertifikat und das frage wie
gehen wir mit erstimpfung also wie gehen
wir mit impfung um die nicht in der eu
zugelassen sind eu vereinbart ist bis
hier hin dass wir bis hierhin nur eu
zugelassene impfstoffe anerkennen
wir werden sicherlich auch dahin kommen
die eu führt ja auch gespräche gesehen
ist das auch immer ein thema gewesen die
am ende sieben übrigens auch vereinbart
bei den gesundheitsministern dass wir
ein gegenseitiges anerkennen wollen der
zertifikate der digitalen übrigens mein
us-kollege ohne aus dem nähkästchen zu
plaudern haben wir berichtet also dass
wir hier mit 27 mitgliedstaaten
einheitlich eine solche app haben und
ein solches zertifikat schaffen andere
noch nicht mehr mit allen bundesstaaten
und insofern ist das schon was
wundert man sich ja auch mal freuen kann
dass das gelungen ist
aber wir haben für die frage wie wir mit
erstimpfung umgehen als deutschland eine
sehr klare position
wie sie wissen dass die eben nicht
reichen und gerade mit blick auf
variante delta indischen
anführungszeichen indische mutation
zeigt sich ja dass der volle impfschutz
wichtig ist und deswegen bleiben wir
auch dabei das volk kämpft geworden sein
muss sondern was die andere impfstoffe
angeht müssen wir miteinander einen
verfahren finden dass diese anderen
stoffe vor allem eins zeigen nicht nur
dass sie gegen kuwait 19 helfen dass die
weko zulassung von impfstoffen ist vor
allem mit blick auf die erkrankungs
vermeidung was für uns aber ja wichtig
ist zumindest noch in dieser phase der
pandemie auch die infektions vermeidungs
zahlen sozusagen wahrscheinlichkeiten zu
kennen
und deswegen werden wir jetzt sinopharm
ist glaube ich gerade in der eu
zulassungsverfahren sputnik v auch wenn
wir die daten kriegen sehen wir wie gut
die auch sind bei den themen und dann
kann man sie gegebenenfalls gleich
stellen das ist aber noch nicht erfolgt
wie kann ich wollte mal fragen also
haben jetzt verschiedene baustellen
gesprochen
es gibt auch viele kritiker jetzt hatte
die spd anfang der woche leicht sagen
indirekt direkt ihren rücktritt wie
haben sie das wahrgenommen oder
beziehungsweise sagen sie dazu und ich
hab noch eine frage von einem kollegen
der nachfrageseite mehrere
ministerpräsidenten jetzt sagen im
herbst wollte doch volksfeste feiern
[Musik]
also im ersten was volksfeste angeht
finde ich das sehr schwer das jetzt
schon für herbst entscheiden zu können
so oder so um die herausforderung für
volksfeste ist ja dass sie frühzeitig
planen müssten idealerweise cannstatter
wasen und die wiesen sind ja schon
adressiert 1 haben wir immer gesagt das
was als letztes wieder gehen können wird
die partie so gern auch ich feiere aber
party großveranstaltungen feiern
karneval wiesen schützenfest ist leider
genau das wo dieses virus sich am
schnellsten ausbreitet menschen
ausgelassen miteinander in den armen
liegen sonst macht volksfest training
wie auch keinen spaß wenn alle abstand
und das ist das was als letztes wird es
wieder gehen
das werden wir in ruhe impfquote haben
und insgesamt damit alles gut unter
kontrolle
aber ich traue mir ob sie sich nicht zu
heute zu sagen dass das im herbst schon
wieder so erfolg geht was die frage
angeht der debatte von anfang der woche
das hat für mich zwei ebenen der seine
ist die frage der sachlichen diskussion
und die kann und soll und muss man
führen über die sicherheit von
schutzmasken über prüfkriterien
überprüft grundsätze die wir ja auch
veröffentlichen
werden ich habe auch kein problem damit
dem deutschen bundestag die
prüfprotokolle müssen wir möglicherweise
in der geheimschutzstelle machen weil da
auch unternehmensdaten und zum teil ja
noch rechtsstreitigkeiten anhängen aber
die prüf 9000 prüfprotokolle zur
verfügung zu stellen
wir haben in der sache stellen wir uns
jeder diskussion und auch jeder kritik
das andere ist die frage geht es um die
sache oder geht es um anderes mit blick
auf auf sonntage mit blick auf stimmung
und das ist der teil an dem ich mir
einfach nicht beteiligen möchte und den
ich auch einfach hin grundsätzlich
schwierig finde innerhalb einer
regierung den ich aber eben vor allem in
dieser phase der pandemie nicht weiter
betreut werden dazu nichts mehr sagen
ich möchte einfach meine arbeit machen
ich möchte dieses land gut durch und
raus aus dieser pandemie führen und der
rest wird dann was jetzt sozusagen die
bewertung der arbeit angeht der 26
september entscheiden lassen sie mich
noch zwei fragen online einbringen
bereiche vom deutschen ärzteblatt fragt
ab wann werden die arztpraxen an das
system angeschlossen die frist für ist
update der praxis verwaltungssystem für
die hersteller geht noch bis zum 12
juli könnte es also noch einen ganzen
monat dauern bis auch ärzte das
zertifikat ausstellen können und der
holstein von der apotheke adhoc fragt
ansprechen sie mit chaos wenn millionen
menschen am montag die apotheken sturm
die noch gar nicht angeschlossen oder
wie die abläufe informiert sind warum
wurden nicht gewagt ist die anschreiben
verschickt sind und wirklich alle
apotheken angeschlossen sind
zur ersten frage wir beginnen heute
schon über die kassenärztlichen
vereinigungen das rollout in die
arztpraxen
wir haben ja auch überbrückungs lösungen
dass die arztpraxen mit einfachen
verfahren den digitalen im zelt das
digitale zertifikat ausstellen können
gleichwohl sind natürlich die praxis
verwaltungssysteme aufgefordert in der
genannten frist integriert im system die
ausstellung des zertifikats zu
ermöglichen
das wird anfang juli der fall sein
spätestens wir führen aber auch
gespräche mit einigen das das natürlich
auch schneller
passieren kann nichtsdestotrotz wir
haben ab heute die überbrückungslösung
verfügbar
wir haben intensive gespräche mit 117 kv
geführt und eine hohe bereitschaft und
motivation wahrgenommen dass jetzt auch
in die fläche auszurollen und das hat
heute begonnen
das kann ich verknüpfe mit apotheken
oder arztpraxen wissen sie es ist ja
auch für uns nicht leichter den
richtigen zeitpunkt für die
öffentlichkeitsarbeit sozusagen zu
finden weil seit es ist jetzt in den
app-stores wenn etwas runter geladen
werden kann wo keiner mehr öffentlich
was zugesagt hat was es eigentlich ist
ist ja irgendwie auch komisch es gibt
berichterstattung darüber dass die
ersten apotheken beginnen werden und
deswegen bei uns einfach wichtig hier
heute das vorzustellen einzuordnen
aber eben auch sehr klar zu sagen da
sind wir wieder bei erwartungsmanagement
es werden jetzt nicht bitte nicht alle
am montag gleich in die arztpraxen und
apotheken sondern das geht jetzt eben
nach und nach ist jetzt mal der druck
ist sozusagen wahrscheinlich auch
unterschiedlich stark
bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern die 1
brauchen das zertifikat vielleicht sehr
bald und sehr häufig andere vielleicht
erst in drei vier wochen wenn es dann in
die urlaubsplanung geht und wer als
erster drei vier wochen braucht kann ja
vielleicht den gesamtsystem noch zwei
wochen zeit geben bevor gleich am montag
sich auf den weg macht wir wollten jetzt
einfach nur vorstellen was jetzt startet
es beginnt halt jetzt die apps sind
verfügbar
die ersten impfzentren arztpraxen und
bald auch apotheken beginnen und
gleichzeitig eben sehr sehr klar sagen
ist können aber noch nicht alle gleich
sofort im laufe des junis werden dann
alle angeschlossen sein
und dann schauen sie mal wenn 20 19 und
20 tausend apotheken mitmachen 70 80.000
arztpraxen und 400 impfzentren dann
werden wir auch einige millionen und der
post viele sehr viele werden auch die
qr-codes erhalten können dieses per post
dauert die länder fangen jetzt an zu
verschicken
10 14 tage maximal maximal
positiv überraschen besser aber
jedenfalls werden wir jetzt eine zeit
kurze zeit dauern aber aber wenn dann
einmal so eine infrastruktur da ist dann
werden auch einige millionen nach
tragung sogar vergleichsweise schnell
gehen können vielen dank wir sind am
ende unserer zeit wie heute alle die
nicht rangekommen sind in online bei
denen wahrscheinlich entschuldigen
herr minister den herren bis zum
nächsten mal dankeschön